[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
me entendieron
alguien me entendió que levante la mano
quien pudo entenderme
bueno de eso se trata la discapacidad
según la convención de la onu del 2006
la discapacidad surge de la interacción
entre las barreras debidas a la actitud
y al entorno de la sociedad que impiden
su participación plena y efectiva en
igualdad de condiciones con los demás es
decir que la discapacidad tiene que ver
con las deficiencias de las personas
pero más tiene que ver con las barreras
que impone la sociedad o que simplemente
no hace nada para quitarlas
si yo hoy hablará solamente en lengua de
señas la gran mayoría de ustedes
estarían presentando a su hija una
discapacidad
y lo que yo vengo a decir hoy es que la
mirada sobre la discapacidad la debo
transformar yo la tenéis que transformar
vos la tenemos que transformar todos
lo que dije antes en lengua de señas es
que mi nombre es el n y hoy venía a
hablar de fotografía y discapacidad
hace algunos años comencé en el mundo de
la fotografía y cuando creía que estaba
en el mejor momento de mi carrera porque
tenía un montón de eventos un montón de
trabajo quedé embarazada y después de un
embarazo de alto riesgo nació mi hija de
forma prematura con 690 gramos
en ese momento entendí todo todo lo que
tiene que ver con la vida y también con
la fotografía pero después de unos meses
ella logró recuperarse pudimos volver a
casa pudimos volver al trabajo y no es
que uno se olvida todo lo que pasó sino
que simplemente uno se va metiendo en la
rutina y poco a poco va perdiendo esa
perspectiva
pero la vida se encargó de recordármelo
y cuando ella estaba por cumplir dos
años le descubren hipoacusia bilateral
profunda
es decir que un momento para otro
nuestra hija quedó sorda por completo
en ese momento no podía dejar de
trabajar tuve que ocupar la cámara como
una herramienta de trabajo y en general
para poder costear todo lo que
significaban los viajes los médicos la
cirugía la rehabilitación entonces
trabajé un montón con la cámara cuando
pasó todo eso cuando ella ya estaba
operada entré como en una crisis
creativa con la cámara me empezó a
costar cada vez más tener que salir a
trabajar tenemos que salir a sacar fotos
y había perdido esa conexión que yo
antes tenía que hacía que la cámara sea
mi herramienta de expresión
en medio de esa crisis me pasa de
conocer a big y vicky es una nena que
viene una sesión de primer añito y
durante la sesión los padres me cuentan
de que ella tenía una enfermedad que era
como una bomba de tiempo pero que venía
muy estable a los tres meses vamos a
hacer una sesión al aire libre como
habíamos acordado y apenas llegó al
lugar me doy cuenta de que pasaba de
algo raro cuando terminamos las fotos me
animé y le pregunté si estaba todo bien
y me dijeron que no que vi que hacía dos
semanas había desmejorado y ese mismo
día antes de la sesión ella ya había
convulsionado seis veces
en ese momento dije algunas cosas y
volví y me fui y volví los 50 km de
vuelta a mi casa llorando
me di cuenta de que yo tenía que empezar
a repensar la mirada tenía que prestar
atención a que estaba mirando y por ende
a que estaba fotografiando porque ahí me
di cuenta de cuánto valían para esos
padres esas fotos de vicky bien de vicky
sonrientes de vic y así tan vivas siendo
que ellos estaban en la total
incertidumbre de cómo iba a estar ella
en dos horas en dos días o en dos meses
cuánto valía en esas fotos para ellos
cuánto valen para vos tus recuerdos
de esa revolución de todas esas
preguntas surgió la idea de comenzar con
este proyecto que se llamó a contarme tu
historia en el cual yo publiqué en las
redes sociales una imagen pidiendo que
me cuenten la familia los padres que
quisieran historias de sus hijos de
niños con discapacidad o con historias
de vidas especiales que yo me iba a ir
acercando iba a ir fotografiándolos y
usando la herramienta la fotografía para
ir contando sus historias como objetivos
yo tenia primero devolverle al mundo un
poco todo lo que nos había dado todo el
apoyo que la gente nos había brindado en
todos los procesos que fuimos
atravesando con nuestra hija como
segundo objetivo era demostrar que ellos
también podían ser modelos que las
personas con discapacidad también podían
ser modelos y tercer objetivo era
utilizará la fotografía como una
herramienta para hablar y visibilizar la
discapacidad
a medida que empecé a conocer todas
estas historias me fui dando cuenta
primero de que ella estaba en deuda de
nuevo de que todo lo que yo le podía dar
no era nada a comparación de todo lo que
ellos me brindaban a mi segundo
descubría la fotografía una herramienta
de inclusión descubrí una herramienta
capaz de sanar descubrí una herramienta
capaz de transformar las historias de
esas familias y por supuesto que también
descubrí en la fotografía una
herramienta que me ayudó a resignificar
mi propia historia la de mi hija y su
discapacidad
y saben qué más descubrir descubrí que
la peor discapacidad es no poder mirarse
a uno mismo no poder tomarse el tiempo
estar a solas con uno repensar qué es lo
que estoy haciendo qué es lo que estoy
mirando qué es lo que quiero hacer y por
qué esa es la peor discapacidad porque
no tiene que ver con las barreras que
nos impone la sociedad sino con todas
esas barreras que nos imponemos nosotros
mismos y a veces ni siquiera nos damos
cuenta
creo que antes de hablar de inclusión
antes de hablar de discapacidad es
necesario que empecemos a transformar
nuestra mirada es empecé es necesario
que empecemos a mirarnos a nosotros
mismos y a las personas con las que
convivimos a las personas que nos rodean
con más paciencia con más cariño con más
empatía
si logramos transformar la mirada entre
nosotros y los que convivimos
diariamente las miradas sobre la
discapacidad se va a transformar sola
ahora los invito a que se imaginen un
poquito que les toca a ustedes
imagínense
que les tocó a ustedes que te tocó a vos
imagínate imagínate que naciste antes
qué tuviste complicaciones
imagínate que te toca un síndrome
imagínate que no podés caminar
que no podéis escuchar
imagínate que no podés ver
imagínate que vivir con una traqueotomía
que no conoces el sabor de los alimentos
imagínate que vivís con botón gástrico
imagínate que vivís en sillas de ruedas
o en sillita postural
imagínate que ni siquiera poder sostener
bien tu cabeza
imagínate que vivís con internación
domiciliaria
qué vivís de terapia en terapia o en
rehabilitación
imagínate que los inviernos la pasas
encerrado para no enfermar o que tus
paseos son solo a turnos médicos
imagínate que ya supera hasta un montón
de cirugías o incluso imagínate que te
quedaste en el camino
imagínate que toda la vida como la
conoces a hasta ahora es simplemente
otra de otra manera
ahora imagínate que no te tocó a vos
pero si le tocó a tu hijo
le tocó a tu sobrino
imagínate que le tocó a tu hermano
imagínate que le tocó al hijo de tu
amiga oa tu alumno o imagínate que le
tocó a tu nieto
imagínate que le tocó a alguien que amas
que no daría para cambiar un poquito
este mundo
que no daría por hacerlo un poquito más
sensible más empático más para todos
la discapacidad nos impulsa a crear
nuevos mundos posibles
y yo sueño con un mundo donde no sea
necesario hablar de inclusión
donde no hagas falta mostrar lo que hay
detrás de una discapacidad
sueño con un mundo donde no sea
necesario mostrar lo que lucha una
familia
las barreras de la cotidianeidad
la burocracia de las obras sociales
la falta de salida laboral
los silencios que duelen las miradas que
juzgan
la incomodidad de lo que no se está
acostumbrado a ver
sueño con ese nuevo mundo un mundo en el
que si yo fotógrafa hago este tipo de
sesiones no llame la atención yo sueño
por ese nuevo mundo lucho por ese nuevo
mundo y trabajo por ese nuevo mundo por
qué
porque que no harías si te tocara vos
la mirada la debemos transformar entre
todos la empatía debe empezar por uno
[Aplausos]
[Música]